possible at this altitude I can on flat
out for a half-mile before my hands
start shaking somewhere else you're
posting for now I'm a cybernetic
organism living tissue over medical
facility this episode is brought to you
by soothe dot-com the world's largest
on-demand massage service what and let
me tell you I have a high bar for this
stuff I have body work done at least
once a week
because I broken my body I have 30-plus
fractures and 100-plus MRIs I need body
work so I have a very very very high bar
for that sooth which I've tested I
tested my assistants tested my employees
tested delivers a hand-selected licensed
and experienced massage therapist to you
in the comfort of your own home Hotel
our office in as little as an hour I've
tested them in San Francisco I've tested
them at Austin obsessed with them all
over the place and I have to say I was
really really amazed at the quality of
therapists and I do not accept
mediocrity at all in this area the
process is super simple think of it as
you remember for massages right you
choose the kind of massage you want say
Swedish or sports massage deep tissue
whatever then if you want you can up for
a couples massage I imagine that's an
edge case as the tech people say but
whatever you set the lengthier massage
so you let's say you want 60 minutes 90
minutes two hours and let's be real if
you want a proper massage go for 90 120
minutes for God's sake and you select
the gender of your therapist and then
click you're off to the races and they
bring the massage table sheets oil music
so you can unwind no matter where you
are and I have used this at Airbnb s
hotels etc sooth is in 50 cities
including most major US cities as well
as London Sydney Melbourne Toronto and
Vancouver so number one download the app
soothe s
Oh th e in the iOS App Store Google Play
Store and then use the code let me try
that again use the code Titans 20 TI ta
n 2-0 Titan 20 all caps to get $20 off
of your first massage that's a lot
that's a very good discount so you
should use it
so again download the app soothe soo th
e and try out the code Titan 20 all caps
for $20 not % $20 off your first massage
and if you're anything like me I have
been paying and I've been enjoying so
give it a shot try out soothe and your
muscles nervous system and sleep well
thank you for it
what the gotta read was that it was
pretty good that's what I think okay
enjoy bye
this episode is brought to you by
LegalZoom I have used legals in myself
for many of my businesses and many of
the icons on this podcast have actually
used Legal Zoom for instance Matt
Mullenweg of WordPress fame CEO of
automatic which is now worth more than a
billion dollars first incorporated his
company on Legal Zoom Legal Zoom is a
reliable resource that more than a
million people have already trusted to
help with their businesses whether
that's setting up a will doing a proper
trademark search forming an LLC setting
up a non-profit or finding simple cease
and desist letter templates man do I use
a lot of those LegalZoom is not a law
firm but they do have a network of
independent attorneys available in most
states they can give you advice on the
best way to get started provide contract
reviews and otherwise help you run your
business and important there are no
surprises Legal Zoom provides complete
transparency that means upfront pricing
customer reviews and a satisfaction
guarantee
check out legalzoom.com today to see how
they can make life better and easier for
you in your business if you're
pretending to be a lawyer on the
internet then you are asking for trouble
put together the safety nets get your
t's crossed and your eyes dotted enter
promo code Tim T IM at
go zoom com2 save 15% that's t IM for
15% off check it out legalzoom.com hello
boys and girls this is tim ferriss and
welcome to another episode of the tim
ferriss show where it is my job to
deconstruct world-class performers to
figure out how they do what they do and
to dig into the details that you can
apply to your own life and this episode
we have a treat we do not have an
entertainer we do not have an actor we
do not have a military strategist we
have a performance specialist
specifically athletic performance and
Ryan Flaherty on instagram at Ryan
Flaherty one the number one was
introduced to me by dr. Peter
attea and those of you who have heard my
episodes with Peter Tiye know that many
good things come from Peter this is no
different
Ryan Flaherty is the senior director of
performance at Nike prior to holding
that position Ryan was the founder and
president of prolific athletes LLC a
sports performance facility in San Diego
California where he trained some of the
world's best athletes his clients
include you may have recognized or heard
of these names Serena Williams
Russell Wilson the Arizona Cardinals
Marcus Mariota Jameis Winston and
hundreds of other professional athletes
and while he's perhaps best known for
dramatically improving his athletes
athletes athletes that's the right word
speed more and more athletes and coaches
see crying out for his training and
guidance on injury prevention and we dig
really deeply into that in this episode
many of his clients have made remarkable
recoveries from injuries and several NFL
teams and European soccer clubs have
sought out his methodology to implement
into their own training programming Ryan
developed an algorithm called a force
number that is based on the trap bar
deadlift also called the hex Bar
deadlift and body weight to predict
speed such as the 40-yard dash this was
a really fun interview we got into the
weeds we got very very nerdy if you
enjoys for instance the Pavel Toulon
episodes the Charles Poliquin episodes
Dominik D'Agostino or Peter Chia the
you are going to love this one it takes
us a few minutes as it almost always
does to warm up
it's a limbering up around and then we
get into all sorts of stuff we talk
about exercises for reducing injury
potential we talk about the force number
and exactly how he uses trap bar
deadlift what do exact workouts look
like sets and reps rest intervals lay it
out start to finish from warmup what
does one of these workouts look like we
talked about gluten eat exercises
perhaps you saw some in tools of titans
computer tias profile that was directly
from ryan and variations we get into all
sorts of nitty-gritty details how he
helped Meb Keflezighi
I think it is trained for his stunning
Boston Marathon victory how does he go
from sprinting to long distance running
how does he predict which athletes are
going to get injured so whether you are
trying to become a better athlete you
are trying to become less injured or
more resilient in any type of training
or maybe if your bookie looking to bet
on different teams and athletes or bet
short certain teams they're going to get
injured there is something for everyone
so please enjoy my conversation with
Ryan Flaherty the savant of speed Ryan
welcome to the show hey thanks for
having me appreciate it I have been
hoping to connect for quite a few months
now and we've had a few actors behind
the scene trying to connect us another
few months and here we are so I'm super
stoked dig in and I thought we could
just start with some basics so you are
very well known for saying that speed is
teachable coachable but almost everyone
out there says it is not it is an 8 so
how did you come to that conclusion sure
I mean you know first and foremost I
think when I was at when I was a young
kid I'm a funny story but when I was
young I was playing baseball and both my
parents path let Akande and you know so
they kind of knew some things about
sports and I would you know hit I was
that bad I hit a line drive to center
field and I got thrown out at first base
and I can remember my dad yelling
unhitch the trailer as I was running I
was running so slow basically which is
not a good thing for a young kid to hear
from his dad
in third grade but I was you know I was
really a really slow kid at when I was
young I grew fast and and just couldn't
develop speed all the kids were faster
than me in my class and my teams and so
my mom actually put me into track and
field when I was young and about fourth
grade and by the time I was in fifth
sixth grade I was the fastest kid in my
school
and and what a lot of that was from was
just me understanding and learning how
to run properly and so once I did that I
kind of opened my eyes to the idea that
you know obviously it was not something
I was born with in any way but it's
something that was learned and it was a
skill that I really put a lot of time
into understanding and learning and you
know I got an older and I've been in the
sports performance you know training
field for a long time
one of the things that I think is you
know kind of funny to me as I point out
a lot of people and parents is that you
know if you can imagine if every sport
played was in the in the swimming pool
one of the first things most kids would
do would be learn how to swim and yet
every single sport on ground is requires
running and yet we don't teach kids how
to run it's just kind of like throw them
into the sport and they'll figure it out
but that's one of the big things I think
I've been trying to help educate people
on is that the one four most important
thing you can do for your child is just
teach them how to run properly and in
every other sport will kind of come
easily to them and I think you know over
the years of more and more research
putting into this I've come to realize
quickly through you know just the
research is that speed is actually a
skill you can learn in it and something
you can train also and it I mean it
seems to me like you have just as you
said I didn't learn to swim speaking as
someone who's extremely terrified of
swimming and for a host of reasons
didn't learn to swim properly until
early 30s yes it is it is incredible
that anything on land that is dependent
in part whether it's NFL Combine and
you're doing something like a shuttle
run I mean the difference between first
place and say third for third also-ran
is I highly depend on the technique
number one but also certain attributes
that you can develop and I'd look for
you to share with us perhaps some of the
experiments that you did at USA Track
to figure out how to better coach speed
yeah absolutely so what I end up taking
I well I needed a sample size that was
that are all like simmer skill level and
talent level and so I took thirty you
know Olympic a standard sprinters and
random unforced played treadmills and so
the Olympic a snare spinners or spinners
that have hit the required marks to
qualify for the Olympics now in the
United States difference is because
we're such a high level that you have to
be much better than than just the
standard but in other countries and a
lot of other countries you get the
standard you're in and so I took I took
Olympic a standard sprinters and I test
them on a force play treadmill and what
I quickly realized was it wasn't about
how much force they were creating or how
great their technique was it wasn't
really until I realized that and I think
I know you're familiar with the study
that was done by dr. Peter Weyand which
is mass specific force is is kind of
king it's more than anything it's how
much force you can create over what your
body masses so to use an example would
be like if I told you go running having
meter dash is faster you could with a 50
pound weight vest on and I bet you know
and record your time and we took it off
and then we recorded your time you'd be
much faster without depending on well
and firstly if you were just increased
somebody's lower body strength by 50
pounds without adding a single pound of
lean muscle mass you'd also have the
same result with improving their times
based on them improving the lower body
strength to mass ratio and so quickly.i
you know through that the study of all
the athletes I realized okay so so much
majority of what it comes down to for
sprinters or for people to be fast is
they have an same amount of strength
over what their body masses so an
incredible ratio between that strength
to weight ratio and so it with every Ave
train now whether it's Serena Williams
on the tennis court or you know a
football player that's going into the
NFL Combine it's about teaching them how
to improve that strength strength to
weight ratio without increasing any lean
muscle mass so I think that's that's the
key and then and then secondarily that
you know mechanics play a part and part
of those mechanics if you imagine when
you run when you watch an athlete run
from the side of their foot in their
swing phase when they're running looks
like it make it's making a circle well
if you have a big circle a big wheel
that would cover a larger distance than
a smaller wheel will and so what I try
to do is help them understand
how to make larger wheels with their
feet in order for them to cover more
ground which increases their stride
length which in turn helps them run
faster times like to give you an example
Usain Bolt takes 42 steps to run our
meter - next best guy in the world takes
44 and so ultimately what you're trying
to do improve you somebody's speed is
helping them limit the amount of steps
they take to run whatever particular
distance they're going whether it's a
marathon or its 100-meter dash which is
also in some respects very comparable to
Olympic swimming right I mean you look
at the source stride length and
efficiency of top swimmers and there's
there's a direct parallel okay it just a
just a side note I guess which I've
always wondered you hear a lot say in
certain running communities about
striking with the mid foot and so on how
much attention do you pay to the the
impact point on the foot when you're
trying to say increase the size of that
wheel does that naturally lead to more
impact closer to the heel or is that is
that something that has been
over-emphasised you know I don't think
it's been over-emphasised as much as it
is the placement underneath the pelvis
so I think more than anything it's kind
of like where the foot striking in
relation to the center of mass is most
important so when you're looking at
somebody who's with a mid-foot strike so
I do focus on mid-foot strike but more
than anything I focus on where that
mid-foot strike is occurring whether
it's occurring you know out you know
middle meters in front of the pelvis if
directly under the pelvis or slightly
behind the goal is to get it as
underneath the pelvis as possible so you
want the foot mid-foot strike to happen
under the pelvis which is more of what I
focus on in that big circle the mechanic
the teaching of the mechanics with
making that heel you know if you can
imagine the heel stepping over your
opposite knee when you sprint is the
goal and so and then a non-grant upon
ground contact and the landing phase you
want the foot to be as directly under
the pelvis as possible and for sprinters
do you how much do you think about
stride rates people have read Born to
Run they're many books and they talk
about well you should go from say 90 and
aim for 180 and you should use some type
of metronome or or auditory feedback so
that you're increasing your
your steps footfalls per minute
effectively well how do you think about
that in the context of what you do if if
you do it all
yeah totally no I absolutely do I think
I think the biggest thing is it's again
everything I'm going to talk about today
it's all about specificity as you know
like once if you're training for
performance and for a particular sport
performance and you're going to train a
very particular way that we're focused
on on you know the minutiae of those
things that will best help that person
perform better however when you're
transitioning into more of like a you
know static runner or just in terms of
training for health a lot of what I'm
going to say may not always apply it but
it kids can apply in certain ways and so
I think with that being said I think you
know the way I look at is stride length
and strike frequency the majority of the
time are products of how much force you
create with the ground of what your body
weight is so your massive cific force
your stride rate stride rate and and
length is actually a product of that so
more than anything instead of focusing
on that I'm focusing on one one handle
mechanics of sprinting but I'm also
focused on if I know if I can improve
strength to weight ratio in a way which
I think we can get a little bit more
depth later is I know for a fact that
stride length and stride frequency will
also improve those are byproducts
exactly and so instead of focusing on
one or the other I just focus on the one
that affects together
so let's I'm sorry I'm so nighted to
jump into into this again a little
overzealous go ahead no worries and I
think that's the biggest thing upon all
the research I've done even in the
weight room is I'm looking at the
exercises that can have the greatest
effect and in a multitude of ways not
just in one specific area so I think
because athletes just like human beings
have have a limit in the amount of time
they have in a day they don't want they
can't and and and trainers can't spend
the amount of time in the weight room
that most people think they can because
they have all these other things going
on you know and so it's what can I get
the most bang for my buck to improve the
most amount of things in the shortest
period of time is what I do with elite
level athletes just like I would with
CEOs or recommend it for you know differ
people in terms of that don't have the
time to spend two hours in the gym you
want to get the most bang for your buck
and so I've really focused on
researching exercises that give you that
in order for them to get the greatest
improvement could you and this might be
a good place you tell me to segue or
it's not really a segment because it's
all there
related force number can you talk about
what that is yeah absolutely and so when
I was studying the speed and sprinters
with yours which I could feel about what
I found quickly was that once the at
once that sprinters hit a certain
distance right around 30 to 40 meters
they actually maintained and held the
exact same split for the rest of the
race it was actually the athletes who
ran at fast times like these st. bolts
of the world were actually ones who were
slowing down the least but really when
you looked at the 10 meter splits is
almost identical all the way through the
finish and so what I what I what I came
to realize quickly was that there was a
correlation there between who could hold
the top and to be the longest and who
was winning the race and so when I was
looking at that and then then inversely
was looking at the athletes and then
measuring a mass specific force the
force by treadmill where I realized
quickly was okay there's relation to the
athletes who have the high
strength-to-weight ratio or the force of
mass specific force force to mass ratio
on the treadmill that also are covering
the same you know lowest splits and
their ten minute they're flying tens in
honor of your - that all of the athletes
came to me after that like this is
awesome this is great
you know but like hey how do we have how
do we improve this and it was it was
kind of a light bulb that went on for me
really quickly was that I think what
most researchers scientists spend time
looking into is diagnostics and
assessments but what most people really
need is ways to improve it so unless you
come with a diagnostic that you can
actually show them improvement and show
them how to improve it if they're almost
meaningless and so I what I spent the
next five years doing was spending time
in the weight room and and and
correlating the data between every
exercise I so I tested the same athletes
in the waiver month with squat PowerCLI
and Hank lean front squat leg press leg
extension are do everything you can
think of Under the Sun and and the and
measured their one rep max and those
exercises their body and their body mass
and compared that to the forceplate
treadmill study and it didn't correlate
until I actually got to the hex bar
deadlift which is also called the trap
bar dead look yeah for a box out there
yep exactly the bar you step into the
handles on the side of the body instead
of the bar being in front right and then
why it's when I started testing the same
athletes with the hex bar dead let the
trap bar deadlift max in their body
weight it actually directly Coral
to the force plate treadmill study at
their max velocity top speed and so I
realized quickly okay if this is the
order in which they ran the hundred
meter dash time in by their hex bar
deadlift maximum body weight and I
improve their X bar deadlift max without
increasing body weight where I see the
same improvement their speed and over
you know past seven years of testing
that I have if you have a not totally
sedentary but former competitive athlete
who would like to use a protocol to
improve this relative strength that
we've been talking about sort of pound
per pound strength output using the trap
bar deadlift or hex bar and what what
might the protocol look like you know
for most people I would I would
generally start them with with somewhat
of a hypertrophy or strength phase for a
while just to get them used to the lift
you just get you know get a lower back
strong enough to be able to get to the
power phases what would that first
hypertrophy phase look like yeah so I
would go I mean I would do probably
three to four sets of eight of your 65%
of your max for one to two weeks and
then I would I would I would shift up
five percent every week leading up to
about eighty five ninety percent where I
would go for reps of five or three so
based on a percentage of your that
you're listing so let's say sixty five
percent you're going to be between six
to eight range there when you start to
get 75 80 percent you want to be in the
five to eight rep range and then when
you get above 85% to 95% you want to be
between two reps and five reps so more
than anything what you're trying to do
altum Utley is what the amount of cross
sectional muscle fiber that your body
currently has you're trying to stress
your nervous system recruit the largest
motor units possible and to do that you
have to leap heavy you have to lift
heavy weights in order to recruit the
larger motor units because ultimately
what most people do when they exercise
they lift weights is that they're
they're stressing their body eccentric
the isometric concentric Li and they're
adding lean muscle mass they're also
recruiting motor units but they're also
but they're also adding lean muscle mass
at the same rate but what we're trying
to do and the cool part about the hex
bar deadlift is at the very top when you
when you push away from the ground here
in the standing position away from the
ground I actually meant to coach you
guys to let go of the bar to drop it so
there's no eccentric movement and the
in the and the exercise so that way you
don't tear sarcomere adding muscle mass
and and now so you're stressed and
nervous is to be a stronger recruit
large motor units but you're not
actually carrying muscle fiber down and
adding more muscle mass and so I would
go every two weeks I was just adjust
five percent and go up five percent for
about four to eight reps for sixty five
percent I would say four to six reps for
like seventeen seventy five percent four
to five reps for eighty five percent
then two to three reps for ninety five
to ninety percent and just progress that
way and everyone it's all relative so it
doesn't mean everyone going to live to
five hundred pounds but but ultimately
what you're trying to get to is an elite
level football player like a four or
five 40-yard dash for four 40-yard dash
would be a three point two times their
body weight in their hex bar deadlift to
run that time three point two times body
weight yeah and what I find it and most
like you know healthy adults they can
they can generally pull it out you know
anywhere from two point two to two point
six times their body weight in the in X
bar deadlift max and what would be a
good objective if perhaps three point
two what would you from the outset if
you said in a in a year's time I would
like to get you to X times body weight
and does it differ for men or women or
is it the same no actually you know it's
kind of funny the same I the funny part
is is what I have like so right now I'm
training a lot of the top NFL Draft
hopefuls guys that just finished their
college career and they come in the way
room they'll see you know some of the
female Olympic sprinters that I have
training and the females are 135 pounds
are dead lifting 440 pounds and they'll
walk it in the first day and I'll hit
385 and it immediately humbled them to
realize what have I been doing for the
past four years of my life because those
group women over there are dead lifting
100 pounds more than I am but it's
pretty funny but in a way to see again
my pencil test exactly yeah
so no no I think you know I mean I think
reasonably over the course of so here's
a question that like what could people
get to over the course of a year yeah
what would your goal for someone who's
reasonably fit but by no means a
n-c-double-a or Olympic sprinter
I think over 2 is a great goal for
somebody like that got it and that is
for one rep maximum or four for a given
rep range yeah so I think over two times
their body weight for one rep maximum so
so to give you an example let's say
you're a hundred pounds your goal is 200
pounds you know four sets of five you
want to want to do 170 pounds for five
that would be you know to get you to 200
as your max gotta be 85% of your max got
it got it so 85% times five five reps
got it and when when someone goes
through the the muscle building general
sort of hypertrophy base building once
they've done that and they're working on
the relative strength and the neural
drive and the recruiting of these motor
units and focusing on that how many
times a week are they doing a trap bar
deadlift workout and what would such a
workout look like sure yeah so I mean
for the elite level athletes generally
I'll have them do it anywhere between
one to two times a week just depends on
the amount of time I have with them for
certain athletes like you know Serena
Williams when I work with her in the
offseason I generally have her like in
November December so I only have two
months with her so it's all kind of
easier into it and build up to two times
a week towards the end but if you have a
long period of time I would go at one
day a week and then alternate with
another complex exercise the second
lower body day you do that week but I
think two times a week and you know if
you're starting hypertrophy phase I
would say four times the eighth at 65% I
like to pair it you know with with some
sort of plyometric to continue to
recruit those you know fast twitch those
larger motor units and then and then
from there I go into all like auxilary
single leg unilateral exercises to help
you know fix imbalances or train the
body in a way that we're not working
bilaterally besides that one X bar
deadlift so I would do an X bar deadlift
the plyo and then some couple single leg
exercises
I'd love to dig into some details so
let's just say let's pretend since I
need the pat on the head let's pretend
like I'm an elite athlete which I'm not
but let's
say I'm ready sir I'm coming in to do
this workout and my body's prepped for
it so I walk in what does the warm-up
look like and then when you get into the
deadlifts what are the sets and reps and
rest intervals like walk me through the
details of what that and of course it's
highly individualized but you can just
make up some we don't even need to get
into the numbers you could use
percentages but what would the the
warm-up and the whole thing look like
yeah so generally I like to do some sort
of a dynamic warmup so some some sort of
movement warm-up not just getting on a
treadmill or on a bike and running or
biking I like to you know do some
walking lunges and walking lunges with a
twist some walking toe touches some quad
you know stretches walking a skip
straight leg skips that type of thing to
kind of get some blood flow and to help
increase range of motion you know I have
athletes start with on a foam roll just
to get again blood flow just to warm the
muscles up a little bit or a power play
some sort of vibration plate if you have
that access to that and then a dynamic
warmup and then I would I would then get
into some activation so I do some like
light glute activation where you do some
hip bridges or something like that just
to fire up the glutes and I do some quad
activation where which would be like
some no weighted step ups you do like
two sets of eight of that by it by
itself and then you get into the hex
board as a form up which would be
probably two to three sets that you know
fifty percent then fifty five to sixty
percent and then we were how many how
many repetitions so I was actually five
and six okay got it five five to six
reps of 50 percent of your working
weight correct yep yep and and then once
you get to 65 percent you'd start your
around and so how many minutes of rest
between the warm-up sets I would say a
minute okay pretty sure yeah yeah you're
going under under a certain and those
are full eccentric concentric eccentric
or you'd wrap okay got it so you're not
dropping the bar on these I am NOT no
god oh all right and and so and then
once you get into the into the into the
working set then it would go
concentrically and I would go and
obviously get right back into position
so it's it stand up drops to end up drop
stand up drop eight times in a row eight
repetitions yep
with
what percentage of your wonder I meant
65% okay got it okay yeah for the first
two weeks it would be like in the
hypertrophy phase and then I would rest
30 seconds and then I would pair that
with like a level one plyometric which
would be like a basic squat jump and I
would do that five times and more than
anything in plyometrics what I think I
really want to kind of get across today
is the goal of him doing plyometrics and
training and for and whether or not they
are just looking to improve you know
your human performance I think the
biggest thing you're trying to prove and
I might use amortization phase which is
the transition between you centric and
your concentric and so to do that you
got to be close or near a hundred
percent so I'm big on in between your
plows resting to do it as hot as hard in
as fast as you possibly can to improve
it a lot of times I think you watch a
training program and you see where
plyometrics start to become more but
like a kind of a conditioning trail you
do it to a plan where you're tired which
is not going to help you improve what
you're trying to prove with amortization
so so I take rest in between so I would
you like five squat jumps we're trying
to explode as high as fast off the
ground as possible and you're doing that
you're doing that in between these
deadlift work sets yes so the superset
would be a hex bar deadlift at 8:00 with
drop and then 30-second rest and you do
your five plyometrics got it up and
you're trying to minimize ground contact
in those playas or how are you what
makes for a good rep than the
plyometrics more than anything you're
trying to you're trying to get to a
depth that you that you feel like it's
natural for you to jump as high as you
can so I'm just looking for somebody to
you know in fight or flight they're
trying to jump as high as they possibly
can I don't really care what that looks
like you would not look like what mine I
think I got up and people get to cup you
know in jumping that stress shortening
cycle that occurs in a lower body when
we jump happens in a window of 250
milliseconds and when we try to perfect
our technique in our squat jumps we miss
that window which doesn't allow us to
explode off the ground as fast as we
possibly could so it's more than
anything it's just get down and up as
quick as you possibly can kind of as if
you you know if it's fight or flight you
know the jump besides you can to save
somebody or something so that's what I'm
looking for and then after that with at
65% I would go with somewhere around a
two to three minute recovery in between
each set right and once you get to 85 to
95% I think as you wrote in your book
prior is when you get to the heavy
percentages you want to go to more of
like a four or five minute recovery
between the lot atp-cp you know fosston
folds regenerate to as close to hundred
percent as possible so sorry my dog is
allergic my dog hates pots for creatine
no she loves it that she loves freaking
out she uses a lot of fuss to create
sorry about that yeah as you get heavier
than you'd be taking longer rest
intervals and for those heavier rates 85
95 percent are you still going to be say
doing a work set then taking was it a 60
second rest you said before the playas
anywhere between 30 to 60 got born
anything you're just looking to recover
it to the point where you can jump it up
as close to you know full effort as
possible got it then do five say five
jumps and then rest for two five minutes
or somewhere in that range and then do
the next set and you do that for in the
case of the hypertrophy we know we're
talking about four sets of say eight
repetitions when you get down into the
lower rep ranges where you're doing two
to five reps at 85 to 95 percent right
max how many sets are you still doing
three to four sets are you doing a
higher number of sets no I'm still doing
three to four okay yep so we finished
the deadlifts what happens after that
then then I would go so all the athletes
right that I bring and I I do forceplate
testing with them so I'll do a
combination of jumps on the force plate
to give me an idea of kind of their that
you know what their rate of force
development looks like or you know II
centrically isometric and centrically
their peak force a lot of different
factors and I'll take that into
consideration on building their
programming for the rest of the exercise
but to just give an example the rest of
the workout will go somewhat
unilateralis all do it all single leg
exercises so the next group of exercises
could could look like a bowl gain
dumbbell bowl gain split squat but for
this particular athlete for you let's
say I wanted to focus on the eccentric
tempo so what I would do with you is I
would have you go you know lower down
for five seconds and then stand up as
fast as you can for one second and you
do three sets of six of that I would
then have you rest again 30 seconds to
60 seconds and I would put you in into a
position where you're seated on a bench
sitting down with
one foot an inch off the ground the
other foots on the ground and do a
single legs concentric plyometric where
you would stand up as and jump as fast
as you can from a seated single leg
position so imagine sitting in a chair
both feet on the ground lifted left leg
off the ground by one inch the right
foots in the ground and you jump off the
right and land on the right only and I
actually have Olympic athletes as I do
this with where they'll actually go from
a seated 90 degree seated position with
one foot and they'll jump onto a 56 inch
box it's pretty remarkable and uh yeah
and so and so I think I don't know if I
can get off the toilet without right one
leg an inch up oh it's nice to meet you
I don't demonstrate because I'm so
embarrassed in front of some of them I'm
like no you demonstrate I'll bring their
athlete in but uh yeah soso working on
on creating power from from a static
seated position right very similar to
how you would if you were sprinting and
so so that's a good example the second
grouping of exercises that I would do
for this for this lower body they got it
and then after the ice lateral exercises
then I would go into some sort of
stability exercise proprioception
exercise where I would go like I call
them step downs but imagine standing on
top of a bench with one foot leg hanging
off the side people the other foot on
top of the bench and just lowering
yourself slowly down for three seconds
and back to standing for three seconds
and I would do some somewhere around one
or two sets of 20 of those more than
anything I'm focused on now that we've
burned through some of larger muscle
groups and the lower body I'm looking at
now the sympathia stabilisation a muscle
so VMO gluta need and getting those
fired up with a step down so it's a
single leg step down three seconds down
three seconds up you're just lowering
yourself over the side of the bench and
back up I'm standing on the edge of the
bench to magic standing on the edge of a
building lowering one foot down three
inches and back up got it and so
that's what is it vastus medialis
oblique Asst and I guess one of the
muscles when weak thought responsible
for a fair number of injuries it would
it would seem or at least ever rest so I
think I think the biggest thing with it
with the VMO that I look at though is
more than anything imbalance so I'm
looking at
asymmetry between the VMO and the rest
of the quad if you look at and I have a
great example of this with a lot of the
NFL guys I'm training right now but when
they come in from college is that they
do so many core complex exercises that
the larger muscle groups kind of
dominate and some of the smaller muscle
stabilizers don't don't get recruited as
much as you'd like and so you'll see
like a guy with a huge quad and a 12
year old girl scout size pretty it's
pretty unbelievable and and that for me
is a big sign that a you know joy
stability instability but number two is
their eye risk and high probability for
lower sure many injury and so that's
something will you know focused on a lot
got it where could someone do you have
any descriptions or any video or can you
point someone to any resources if they
wanted to learn how to do because I want
to learn this single leg step down in
the way you're describing yeah if I
don't already have a video up on youtube
I will put one up there for you and then
also to you know I work with Nike on on
their app that they have which is the
Nike Training Club not to plug or
anything but you got that habits of the
exercises in it it's actually great kind
of resource for different exercises and
things that I do that that's all in
there which you can pull from and it's
free so so it's you know doesn't cost
anything what is your YouTube account
prolific athletes got it alright so
we'll get on that by the time this comes
out guys we'll make sure something is up
for you yeah Olli and then I'll finish
with seven-way hips which you I think
you know all about you'll finish with
one seven way hips which I think could
you describe it yes I do know all about
it I gave I gave the treacherous p2t a
credit yeah dr. Peter Thea mutual friend
of course who I described well I shared
a lot from Peter in tools of Titan's on
pages 61 62 63 and these are glute
medius
root Meade primary exercises that you
taught Peter so that's the seven way hip
yep that's it I'd finish with that
and you do that how many times a week
we're only talking about the trap bar
workouts but let's say you're doing this
once or twice a week is once a week
enough for the seven way hip or would
you do it more no absolutely I mean I
think gluten aids are one of the one of
the muscles I think for most people
causing a lot of issue they don't even
know about especially when it comes to
lower back issues and underdeveloped
gluten group Meads so I think one of the
big things I would do is I would do at
least two days a week of it but I have
two different variations of it that more
and more researchers coming to find that
you actually want to train the glute
need as much as you can in closed chain
so I have some exercises too I also
posted on YouTube account to show you
better close chain which means feed in
contact with the ground to focus on that
glute meet and it will do so maybe like
you know seven way hits one one or two
days a week and then and then a closed
chain blew me to exercise the other day
of the week I think would be perfect
great yeah I know that
Amelia Boone who also appears in tools
of Titan so three-time world's toughest
Muhtar champion does quite a bit of the
closed chain glute made work awesome and
I think videos be super helpful there so
we'll make sure that's up as well may
you did say that glute mean one of those
muscles that when weak leads can common
lately to injury what would you say for
not necessarily professional athletes
but just athletes per se right whether
they're doing CrossFit or Jiu Jitsu or
doesn't matter tennis fill-in-the-blank
right someone who is a recreational
athlete what are some of the most common
culprits in terms of whether it's
imbalances or weaknesses that if you
were to put down a short list like the
four or five that when neglected are
most responsible for the injuries that
you see we'd bloomie be in that top four
or five list I'll absolutely I think
would be to be on top too
okay what's the other one in the top to
ankle flexion ankle flexion that is my
nemesis right there yeah so know about
ankle flexion you basically mean that
sort of dorsiflexion and rain rate and
plantar flexion yeah Andy and
version version as well so I think I
think the biggest thing is in the jaw
everything happens from the ground up so
unless you're a swimmer obviously
there's that's the one kind of caveat
here is that that you know with your
feet in contact with the ground as an
athlete or whether you're CrossFitting
or you're running or anything really at
the end of day we're feet are contact
the ground number one place your look is
feet and ankle flexion so I think that's
a big one especially with majority
athletes I see coming out ankle flexion
is really poor and something we focus a
ton on because now ultimately
everything's connected the fascial
body's connected and so when there's an
issue in the chain at some point other
other pieces up the chain are going to
overcompensate so whether it be you know
more attention and on the knee joint or
it moves up in the pelvis it's going to
always start at the feet so that's where
I think number one is and then glute
Meade number two I was a VMO being
another one which is really hard to
target I think one of the big things
about VMO glutamine is pretty easy to
isolate the most difficult and one of
the ways that I do that is in some of
your training which when you're when
you're doing and I think after you kind
of burned through the quads the glutes
and the hamstrings
once your lower body begins it really
fatigue is when you can then go in and
target the PMO's and you have to be able
to target them through a high high reps
because you're going with you know
you're only using your body weight doing
some isolation exercises for the VMO
like like the steps down that I talked
about which I'll share a video and I'll
share one more other vml exercise which
is really really good you have to go
higher rep high-volume to be able to
target it after you've already fatigued
the larger muscle groups because
otherwise the overcompensating take over
the load so that's a big part of that to
improve and is the is the step-down is
that also called the Peterson step down
or is it technically different the way
they do it
it very well could I have to look that
up but got a yeah imagine like like kind
of a pistol squat on the Hang with one
foot hanging over the side of a bench
but you're only going down to like a 45
degree angle right yep yeah very cool
all right we'll we'll make sure that is
up so you have ankle flexion glute need
VMO any other usual suspects that you
find in that list uh you know this one
not so much of a muscle as much as it's
just
internal rotation of the femur I think
the big one of the biggest amount that
one of the biggest things I find with
the athletes I work with number one is
that they have minimal internal rotation
the femur which is very easily you know
stretching and you can you can find ways
to kind of create the equal external
internal rotation of your female within
your pelvis but I but most athletes come
into new you know really turned out
really lack internal rotation when you
watch a lot of slow motion video which I
do a ton with the athletes that train
when you when you're watching an ACL
injury happen on the field of play what
you see is massive internal rotation of
the femur and that's where the rupture
occurs meses internal rotation internal
rotation of the femur so you see kind of
the knee cave-in going to valgus and
that's where the you know your your
femur tries to internally rotate if you
have range of motion there you that you
can internally rotate you're going to
actually avoid an ACL I have a couple
last week that had took some big hits
like Russell Wilson the cortex and
Seahawks this year that played through
an MCL injury that hit he took nine
times out of ten would have been ACL
tear but based on his ability to
internally rotate he was able to avoid
that it was an MCL sprain only he didn't
miss a practice actually with it as a
pretty brutal hit but that was because
of all of the work we do so like like I
always tell people that I can't
eliminate injuries with the athletes I
train but what I can do is bring that
probability as low as possible which
hopefully keeps them on the field you
know for long periods of time and
forever any given athlete you know I
mean the worst thing that possibly
happen is you know get injured and so if
you can lower that probability I mean
that that's that's the goal what is a
good way to improve internal rotation of
the femur this this is probably also
best shown by video but what would if
you if you if it's possible to describe
the sort of best bang for the buck that
you have found what is a good way to
improve internal rotation of the femur
sure there's a fantastic stretch you can
do up against the wall that I will show
a video of it's really difficult to
explain over over audio but I will I
promise you I'll post all these videos
up so you guys have them to see but
there's one you just basically back
lying against the wall that you can do
that is really helpful okay cool
so we get that in there
an ankle flexion possible to also share
any best bang for the buck there in
terms of improving ankle flexion this is
one I really need personally yes there
is a fantastic tool out there called the
pro flex I have no association with them
and they're going to be stoked I'm
saying this but there's a it's basically
a bro flex drove I like Leggett sounds
yep it's a DCT Pro flex and basically
it's a board they created a physical
therapist created it if the board to
allow you to gain leverage with your
with your calf and so you put your foot
into it looks like somewhat of a little
boot and you put your foot into it and
then it allows you to stretch your
calves in in multiple ways where you
know it's your tip or gastroc but it but
it really focuses and helps you kind of
get stretch in and strengthen through
through the full range of motion planner
and dorsiflexion unlike anything i've
tried out there and it's kind of a
phenomenal product honestly and really
easy to kind of to help you with with
the that flexion all right pro flex
first ones free that's on me then yeah a
sponsor the next podcast aren't the
others so this is related to mutual
friend of ours uh told me a story about
how you told him Robert Griffin the
third rg3 which I thought was c-3po or a
robot because I don't follow team sports
was not going to last very long in the
NFL and you said a very early on in his
rookie season how did it seems like
that's going to be the case so how did
you know that he wouldn't last or had
you suspect that so I mean you know when
you when you look at it's very similar
to how a doctor would look at a patient
if they were really going deep into into
kind of understanding what's going on
with them they look into past history so
you look in the family history to extend
up into you know past ten years of daily
you know habits nutrition exercise all
those things and when you look at
athletes you get an understanding of in
the past what what they've been exposed
to what they do you kind of get a
clearer idea to say I don't need to work
on or what they're going to be you know
at risk of movie moving forward and so
one of the big things was with rg3
coming out with that use known as a
really fast at accuse actually has an
elite level world-class track and field
hurdler at baylor i'm all
actually and so when he came out one of
the things that I noticed quickly was
that just based on looking at him just
from an eye test you could see the
imbalances between no power you could
create how fast he was and again we go
back to the amount of glutamate and the
type of training he was doing when
you're a linear athlete looks like a
track and field athlete running straight
ahead for long periods of time and
that's all you do in train and then you
transition to a sport like football
where you're very very fast because your
track and field backer but they can
transition a football where everything's
happening in different planes you know
you're moving scheduled frontal and
transverse and a lot of multiplanar
horses that are put onto the body that
you have to train a very specific way to
improve those and a big part with what
he missed out on was just training in
order to absorb those forces in multiple
claim that I knew would caused an ACL
injury and so and then watching his
training is you kind of post a lot about
his training with like the heavy heavy
deep squats that he was doing a lot of
that I mean ultimately he was fast
enough he didn't really need to train to
continue to improve his explosiveness
the doodle River was a world-class
hurdler he didn't need to improve that
what he needed to improve was his
ability to prevent and and possibly
avoid injury and and so instantly by
just understanding it what kind of
imbalances track-and-field athletes have
and then transitioning that to what
football is with what what stresses
you're under the ball I could tell
pretty quickly that he was at extremely
high risk more than any other athlete
I've assessed of an injury and and
unfortunately ultimately it kind of
panned out that way but but yeah you can
you can kind of get an idea of someone's
kind of history and passive what what
they do and kind of some of their
imbalances as to what bridges injuries
they're at high risk for I have a an
unrelated question in a very related
question but before I forget I wanted to
ask you because I was recently I've had
exposure to hex bars for a long time
starting in college but I was recently
gifted my first personal hex bar and I
have I have it in my garage in my gym
and there are two height settings I'm
sure you've seen this where one set of
grips if one side is up is roughly the
I would say the same height as the the
rest of the bar so to speak where you're
loading the plates and then there is one
that is slightly higher so my question
for you is when you're doing hex bar
deadlifts how how many inches off the
floor or how high are the grips that you
would use for your athletes so I
generally use high handle high handed
okay yep I handle so there's a high
handle low analyze general use high
handle the reason is because of the
Kurama most the ethics I'm working with
her generally over five ten to five
eleven and they're worth up to six seven
so I'm usually using high handle just
because I don't need to I don't need to
put them in that type of flex on need
them to be that deep and and they're not
that strong at that depth and one of the
main reasons why is when you look at
leats on a football field you rarely
ever see them in this position so I'm
not looking to strengthen that range of
motion we will work to improve
flexibility and strength in different
ways whether it be manually to get them
in those full range of motion but when
I'm training them early it's more I'm
trying to increase the load as high as
possible when you think about the
central nervous system it adapts to
stress so if you're if your lower body
is capable of pulling from a high handle
X bar dead in to 500 pounds but in every
other exercise that you do you're only
able to get to about 380 are you
actually stressing your nervous system
to recruit larger Modi and it if you're
only doing 380 we are capable of doing
over 500 and what I've done is the
answer is no and so with the high handle
what you're able to do is increasing
increasing the degree of your femur and
the positioner pelvis then in your spine
and spinal and all that is that you're
able to go heavier which allows higher
neural adaptation which you're going to
keep recruit larger motor units and so
that's what I'm using X bar deadlift not
so much to you know increase you know
hip range of motion or anything like
that what I'm looking to do is stress
the nervous system in such a way that it
has to recruit larger motor units in
order to pre strengths increased
strength so that's the goal and so with
the high handle you can generally go
heavier and that's why I use it got it
so even for a hobbit
like me I'm like five eight maybe five
nine on a good day if I'm like trying to
put something and tinder or something
but uh it would you suggest in that case
I do have kind of
and soreness arms though so maybe that
means I should also use the high handle
would you still use that with the
shorter athletes people who are under
510 or would you take them to the lower
handle I may take you to the lower
handle but what I also may do is take
your lower handle and maybe add like one
of those you know 10 pound plates
underneath it just give you an extra
inch I don't want you to deep yeah into
it like you would be like in a deep
squat I want you to be in somewhat of an
athletic like jump position to where if
you imagine like looking in the mirror
from the side if you imagine jumping and
you go to the depth of your jump and
that's where you feel comfortable look
in the mirror see where that is and then
align the handles to that because I
don't like position that's where I want
you to be that that's where you can
recruit you're going to recruit me most
for you and I've done more straight bar
deadlift work than I have trap bar where
should my hands be relative to my feet
in other words slightly ahead of my feet
directly in line with the side of my
ankles where do you suggest the hands be
yes okay I mean the one reason the
interesting thing about the head the
straight bar is that where I found one
in testing it is that it had a lot more
to do with your posterior chain and and
what I love about the expert deadlift is
that because of the position the handles
inside your body it kind of it's more of
an anatomically correct position and it
allows your body to kind of recruit more
of its skeletal muscle to help you lift
it and so basically basically you want
that you know grip the middle of the
handles you see the handles has
underling on it you want to kind of grip
in the middle but align your hands right
next to the outsides of your legs so
they should be pulling you straight up
through into your hips so you imagine
drawing a straight line from you're kind
of in your inner knee bent knee position
from your your ankles shins to up to
your hips that's where you want to be so
it's kind of think more bar path than
you do kind of you know start position
anything like that like without weight
kind of go up and down a few times and
kind of see the bar path and that's
where your alignment should be on the
ground got it right so if you were to
extend if you were to extend your hands
in the proper position and do sort of a
high bar back squat type of straight
down
squat your your kind of middle fingers
would be right at the bony process on
the side of your ankles yeah exactly
got assets with kind of alignment of the
hand cool and last last on the trap bar
how important is it to drop the weights
versus lower them very quickly and I'm
not looking for a particular answer here
the reason I ask is that I've seen
people drop in quotation marks and I've
done this to bar quickly versus drop
because it takes them less time to reset
and do another repetition but that may
just be increasing likelihood of injury
with with doing really rapid eccentric
versus just dropping the weight assuming
that we can do either where we're
training which is pretty easy these days
with the proliferation of CrossFit boxes
it love dropping and CrossFit box
ah what would your what would your
thoughts on that be yeah you know so it
all depends I think if the heavier I go
with some of the athletes you know the
biggest limitation is their grip
strength and so a lot of times I'll use
wraps with them to allow them to go have
here especially the females I train when
they can get up to the 400 range or high
300s a lot of times their grip strength
this is incapable of holding on to the
bar and I don't want them to like
increase their grip strength because I'm
not trying to add mass so I add straps
so with straps I'll generally have them
like you know drop pretty quickly
keeping their hands on the handle but
for the most part it's more about you
know efficiency and energy expenditure
so I'm looking at it if it's going to
like require a lot of energy for you to
like to go down with the bar and drop
with it and try to get back into
position quickly we're looking for
effort on every single rep consensually
than I am kind of a fast drop so really
ultimately comes down to you if you're
if you're good and really quick and can
get back into position fast by keeping
your hands on the handle and just
dropping with the bars and I'm fine with
that I've a p2 do that all the time I
think it's just more than anything comes
down to kind of comfort level with it
and more than anything not expending too
much energy in the lowering of the bar
got it and give any preferred strap CEUs
or is just the old-school I call our
school cloths yeah straps those are my
favorite
all right so I promised I would reel us
back to we were talking about and we
talked about ACLs so I recently had my
first ACL injury there may be more to it
I did get MRIs this is about three
months ago I was hiking in Colorado with
a number of guys very aggressive terrain
45 degrees up 45 degrees down lots of
shale and and so on and loaded backpacks
and I stepped up onto a log it was about
a fallen tree that was six three feet in
diameter something like that I stepped
up and as I went to step off with my
left leg my right leg went through the
tree and basically caught right below
the knee and I hyper-extended the knee
it wasn't catastrophic I was able to
continue to hike but I had incredible
pain for weeks afterwards and had
trouble even walking down stairs or
walking around I kind of had to peg leg
around and we're three months out I can
I can do controlled deadlifts even up to
I haven't gone crazy but I can get over
300 without any exhibiting any symptoms
of pain but I do have sub patellar
soreness and this lingering concern
about ACL I have some plans to ski
coming up in a few weeks and I am
concerned about it this is the first
time I've had knee issues per se I've
had a lot of quad issues where I've torn
my legs apart but knee like structural
knee issues this is relatively new for
me so I guess there's there's a short
term question and long term question
short term is I don't feel like I have a
ton of lateral instability but I also
don't really know the hell I'm talking
about because I've never thought of but
I've never worried about it before so
how would you assess whether or not I
should ski or not ski would be short
term and then longer term is what are
some some good ways to minimize well
actually to rehab an ACL injury yeah so
I thought
physical therapists on so number one I
don't want to prescribe anything to you
too you know without kind of a physical
therapist getting their hands on you
here but I do think I mean look I think
physical therapy is an amazing field I
think there's a lot lot happening there
I think will become one a larger kind of
more and more performance will be going
towards physical therapy than that it
will be going the old school kind of
powerlifting route and so I think you
know if you can get into a local
physical therapist I think that would be
ideal I think one of the big things is
what I find is if it's not a rupture of
the ACL it could be you know some sort
of a you know grade two one or two
sprain sprain of the MCL which you know
is all kind of worked through by
movement and Rehab so I think any type
of you know non-weighted stability
strength you can do of the VMO in the
quad would be ideal and also of a group
meet but I would kind of if best you can
get under some professional guidance for
that like at a local physical therapist
if you have one nearby or buddy of yours
that's one but but I think a good test
would just kind of be lightly you know
testing it was just some like light
hopping or some light like jumping and
landing on your single leg like forward
and back and under it's feeling you know
how much pain you have there for the
most part but it but I definitely just
get to get it checked out I think that
sounds I mean but hyperextension is
difficult because it's again what one of
the biggest thing is I'm trying to help
the athletes avoid non-contact knee
injuries but when you have something
that's like you know that shearing force
jarn it that that's femur forward and in
the joint which is probably what
happened when you're hyper extended it
that's those are those are tough those
are tough to understand kind of all the
different forces that went on to kind of
cause that so I don't know I mean but if
you're not in it if you're feeling
pretty easy you're still able to
deadlift you said yeah I'm still a
little deadlift I dead lifted yesterday
with like mid 300s without any pain but
I was doing partial range of movement
pulling basically to just above the knee
from the floor this is straight bar and
dropping I I didn't want to risk I any
type of hamstring injury and if I lift
to the top I'm probably going to be
lowering it quickly just want to avoid
the potential of eccentrically loading
my hamstrings in some stupid way
so I was yeah mid 300s pulling too
just above the knee and then dropping
and these were relatively they were low
rep range so two three reps and then
longer rest periods but ya know for all
intents and purposes asymptomatic after
that like I feel fine today huh yeah
yeah so I'm not my God's gonna come and
just have a sprain but I would go get
checked out
yeah okay cool question so we've talked
about exercises that are high ROI
exercises that can help prevent injury
we talked about the ankle flexion the
pro-flex we talked about gloomy din the
seven way hip VMO and the step downs
internal rotation of the femur and the
weird so weird is hard to describe an
audio okay yeah with the wall stretch
which we'll get video for ya if there
are people who would argue I'm not one
of them really but that any exercise
done properly can be done safely that
having been said there are exercises
that seem to produce more injuries than
others right so if you were talking not
about elite athletes but just aspiring
athletes or weekend warriors in general
right you have a thousand people and you
want to decrease injuries as much as
possible what exercises would you
remissions or anything would you remove
from gyms 100% would be the knee
extension machine knee extension 100%
that machine is be worst for you you
could possibly imagine okay good to know
yeah they're there in every gym and I
think it's kind of like it they have to
be but I would never do on the extension
machine ever again got it okay so knee
extension out so the extensions out what
any any runner-runner runners up in
terms of machines or it doesn't have to
be machine it could be an exercise some
say any any exercise that is just not
worth the hazard or a potential risk of
injury yeah you know I've actually
worked with a lot of Olympic Committee's
all over the world and one of the one
things I always do when I'm with them is
i go and seek out the olympic lifting
coach
kind of just pick his brain and talk him
to them and you know kind of across the
board Olympic lifting coaches would tell
you to not Olympic lifts unless you're
an Olympic lifter and the one reason
they was data is because they take a
lead level Olympic lifters and take
around two years to properly teach them
the technique in a certain lifts whether
it be between a jerk or
clean you know whatever overhead squat
whatever it might be I think the biggest
thing I would say in terms of that I
train a couple CrossFitters and I've
actually just started doing Crossfit
recently just because the crossers I
started training were giving me so much
crap that I've never done it that I was
like fine I'll give it a shot and I'll
you know whatever because I can't I
can't talk trash about them unless I do
it so I'm currently doing that so I
actually enjoying it but I would say
with my background in and actually
science and training for so long I'm
competent in those in those lifts that I
feel safe I can I can do them but I
watch when I'm watching people doing
overhead squatting it just it kills me
like I I can't do it and I see so many
people who are just waiting for some
sort of injury that that it just killed
me so I would just say if you're going
to get into cross room you're going to
get into any type of Olympic lifting
really seek out somebody who's Olympic
you know lifting certified that can help
you you know USA W certified to help you
learn how to do it properly and take
your time learning it before you jump
into it there's a lot of variations you
can do that's what I always tell the
athletes that work with you they're like
well wait we don't power clean and like
know if I can get if I can do other
exercises get the same result but put
pull back all of the risk of injury why
why wouldn't I do that like I'm not
trying to get you I'm not training you
to be a good lift I'm trying you to be a
good full player basketball player
tennis player or not train you to be a
great you know lift or so more than
anything it's trying to trying to
eliminate the risk of injury as much as
possible so I would say if you're going
to go in Olympic lifting CrossFit really
learn how to do that lift and take your
time to do it before you jump into the
classes and just go for you know five
rounds of you know twenty overhead squat
and then the second would be the knee
you know lot extension machine in the
gym is the worst possible she you can
you can ever do besides the trap bar
deadlift and I know we've already
mentioned a few besides the the hex bar
deadlift if you had to pick one exercise
- or stretch to have everyone do if you
wanted to one shot one kill try to
decrease injuries across the board and
it or as many injuries as possible just
per se a group of a thousand people what
would what would you have them do oh
that's a good question I mean III mean
seven-way hits the one you put into
designs I think would be a really really
good one for most people to jump in and
do but if we're looking at like not
something some exercise I like you know
came up with in my room trying to
torture people I think something that's
common I would say Bulgarian split squat
I really like I I also really like box
squatting I think box squat is a great
way to kind of teach somebody the proper
sequencing and movement without you know
putting them at risk of injury so I
think those two be good exercise for
people to go start with and then that's
the massive improvement and what height
box would you have someone start with
generally just you want to look in the
side of the mirrors sit down on a box
and you're looking for my degree angle I
got it all right so you're looking for
90 degree angle meaning quads parallel
to the ground effectively and then got
it yeah
all right now the so this this is
something I'd love to dig into and this
relates to story of how you helped meb
and you're going to have to pronounce
this guy's last name for me I could plug
these gay alright train for his
incredible Boston Marathon victory so
can you explain for us maybe tell the
story of what inspired you to apply your
sprinting insights to marathoner and how
you trained him yeah I mean just really
really simply stride length and
frequencies product of master to explore
so you can help someone increase their
master dick force naturally those two
things are going to occur when you're
marathon runner on average will take
around 20,000 strides to run a marathon
well if I can increase your stride
length because if increase your master
civic force and your normal running gait
by 2 by 3 inches let's say right so big
increase 3 inches on every normal
running great in your stride length 3
inches times twenty thousand six
thousand choose which is around five
thousand feet which is close to a mile
so you're a mile ahead of where you were
last time you ran that marathon just
purely by increasing mass specific force
that simple got it and what how did your
training differ if at all for meb purses
your sprinter damaged sprinters meaning
track and field or football players fill
in the blank yeah so so so majority of
marathoners don't have a don't have a
kind of desire to get in the weight room
and strength train I think a lot of you
know kind of for a long time thought
it's been that it can only go to to hurt
you an injury or add size which is what
most marathoners don't want and so the
biggest thing was just teaching him that
by x-bar deadlift you know training and
just two concentric zone only so not
doing no eccentric loading that he could
again stretch his nervous system recruit
motor units without larger loadings
without adding any any weight so he
started 127 pounds and at 127 pounds and
and by just increased that one
exercising that I didn't touch his
running I didn't touch anything else
that he did in the weight room it was
just simply that one exercise once a
week it improved his his started like
this running gait in turn helped him run
faster love it love the simplicity of it
I mean yeah super efficient rightful
doesn't mean easy but no I like the
elegance I biggest thing I mean I think
you know one of the things I've always
kind of really loved about which what
you're doing same kind of approach I
take you look a lot of people that that
there's this one what they do I think
they take that temp approaches you look
at patterns you just look at what you're
trying to do is you're trying to look at
the most important things you can
actually have control over to improve
that has the greatest effect the most
amount of ways but with the simplest
approaches just keep it as simple as
possible I think that really not only
helps yeah I mean elite level athletes
but helps everyday people I think that's
the biggest misconception I always have
people ask me you know what well they're
elite athletes and you know I started
work with Nike you know
well yeah but you know take a part where
you do with elite level athletes and
apply that to everyday people and them
and I always try to say is that there's
nothing different I mean with the
exception of they may be genetically
predisposed to have greater talent in
catching a ball or throwing a ball fast
or running fast or whatever it might be
ultimately their time in their day is
the same as yours their their ability to
and
how hard certain workouts are the same
as yours it's just that you know there
may be training for just a little bit of
a different purpose so they're still
looking for the most bang for their buck
and trying to you know keep it as simple
as possible even though they're elite
just like the everyday are definitely
now what do you you mentioned Nike what
are you working on and Nike that you can
talk about I know the show that's
probably off the table but what l what
would have you been recruited to do you
know I think the biggest thing is just
is that the performance training and
fitness field is big it's growing you
know really quickly I think people are
really starting to understand how
important and this is for their overall
health and and so I think what my role
at night gives the senior director of
performances is to really help kind of
bring bring in and using lycra nitric
trainer network or the performance
Council of some of the top minds in the
field to help kind of funnel information
and in training modalities and ideas and
workouts into an app experience for
everyone to be able to to use and kind
of as a way so it's a free app called
Nike Training Club which I'm working on
it's basically a personal trainer your
pocket so our goal is there's different
technology will be coming out with soon
that we'll be able to give you really
in-depth assessment of you know where
you're starting from your imbalances
weaknesses those types of things and
kind of prescribe a training program
using algorithms that will be unique to
you and helping you improve whatever
you're trying to prove whether it's
weight loss or you know strength gain or
getting ripped or running a faster half
marathon or if you're a game-day athlete
at the high school level trying to make
your football team it's going to be you
know geared and unique for you based on
your assessment so just kind of bring
together the best minds in the field
that I can bring together and that nice
to bring together to kind of deliver
that through digital experiences big ole
cool can't wait to check it out yeah we
were talking you mentioned earlier your
eyes bleeding when you watch people
doing horrific overhead squat attempts
especially if they're trying to do as
many reps as possible and have been
happier they're already about to pick
the brains out or something like that
which by the way people wondering a lot
harder to do a proper overhead
wat then you would think you need well
most people would be very good ankle
flexion really good thoracic mobility so
they they're not completely destroying
their shoulders besides that what other
things and it could be anything
doesn't have to be exercises what other
stuff drives you crazy when you see it
at a gym good question
besides besides guys and like affliction
t-shirts doing preacher curls while they
stare into their eyes in the mirror
besides that oh man uh I will funny so
romantic but you know I think I think
the big what oh I hate I hate people
running on treadmills that's number one
why do you hate people running on
treadmills just I just think it promotes
just bad running mechanics I think it's
just that people kind of tend to like
roll that way when they there's a street
right outside they can just go run on um
and there's a lot of technology out
there that helps them track and I get an
idea of exactly what they're doing of
treadmill just on the road but I think
you know I don't know that's tough I
think it's already told about leg
extension machine that one kills me what
else
okay well the good I can't go to a high
school or younger path game to watch
people run it drives me absolutely crazy
like I can't watch people run that
haven't been taught how to run properly
and they're just you know doing butt
kicks behind them all backside mechanic
but like just watching people not how to
run know how to run properly is my pet
peeve I think that that one I have a
hard really hard time or like it when
you watch somebody going on a run on the
side of the road and like I really just
wanna pull over stop and get out of the
car just work on their mechanics with
them just like five minutes and it will
save them so much pain and injury but
and most of its just by over-striding I
think biggest could do they clean volume
in Lenna instead so when you think about
I talked about earlier when you think
about foot strike when when the foot
strikes way out front in front of your
pelvis when your foot let bun pon grande
ground contact is out in front of your
pelvis from when you're one of while
looking at somebody from the side that's
that's over-striding and I think that's
the number one cause of injury and
static running if you talk to a lot of
physical therapists and so just that
alone if you can help fix
over-striding help eliminate a ton of
injury in static runners so that's kind
of a mission of mine what are some of
the tips that you would give in those
five minutes to fix over-striding is it
more forward lean is it I have no idea
I'm not a runner but what would your I
know a lot of people who are certainly
what would some of the recommendations
be they would give that person in in
your five minutes once you've convinced
them you are going to mug them or say
you weren't pretty completely insane
well that's the hard part I think is
that it difficult to do it I mean a lot
of times I was just telling in my voke
on by the other day they were asking
like what you know what you're teaching
me it feels so uncomfortable and awkward
I was like exactly you're slow so
therefore being fast should feel
uncomfortable and awkward
that's like things faster so
uncomfortable awkward we have a problem
because you're not you're good I think
that's the hard part is that it should
it should feel a little bit awkward and
comfortable when you first start doing
it right so it's difficult to do it on
your own without somebody watching you
from the side but generally it's just
the feeling of your foot landing almost
almost behind you like directly under
you or behind you and you'll know most
likely its landing someone underneath
you so kind of get that feeling of foot
placement underneath you or behind you
and I think that will help a lot just
don't reach out in front of you to run
got it
what what do well here I'll give you two
questions you can answer either one so
one is what is something you believe and
it doesn't have to be limited to what
we've been talking about but what is
something you believe that other people
think is insane
or what do if you had to pick one thing
you believe that a lot of trainers
disagree with you on what would that
thing be could be either you know I
think although
probably a lot and I think a lot let's
get into it whenever you want whatever
you convention yeah you know I think the
number one thing is that but my biggest
frustration in the field of training
Human Performance is that I think
everyone's constantly trying to be the
expert and making things so complicated
that you have to see a trained
professional to understand I think my
biggest thing is that it's not that
difficult it's very simple and I think
the more this work the simpler we can
make it the better it is for everybody
including the ones those teaching it I
think we try to get so complicated and
and and you know kind of put on spin and
making it were the expert in certain
things that it just becomes kind of
undigestible for most people so I think
my biggest thing is just make it as
simple as you possibly can whether
you're working with elite level athletes
or you're working with you know you know
sedentary adult side it doesn't matter
it's just just make it as simple as
possible because ultimately you can only
improve so many things at once just
focus on on whatever you get the most
bang for your buck out of it and I think
start there and you can start to add
things on and and I think that's the
biggest thing I think you know for me I
think it's just it's just keeping it as
simple as possible and I think we try to
make it wait a lot more difficult I
think people always say well you know
how do you calculate on just an expert a
looking body weight well you know
there's an algorithm that goes into and
there's been eight years of data
collected on you know thousands of
athletes that helped me drive to that
it's not just now just do this amount
and it you know there's a lot that goes
to it but by me just keeping it really
simple by just saying just increase your
strength without increasing the most
messing you you'll improve your speed it
I think it's more helping more people in
it than it is kind of I can't tell that
so it's not that I'm trying to tell
anything is more than anything is just
trying to keep it as simple as possible
so people kind of remove the riffraff
from from you know the daily thing I
don't if you saw the story there's a
story today in on ESPN about the
University of Oregon and there's three
players from the University Oregon's
football team that were hospitalized due
to rhabdo which geez
so that's rhabdomyolysis you want to
describe what what rhabdo is for people
who don't know yeah sure it's basically
caused by super intense workouts
overtraining to the point where your
muscle tissue breaks down gets in the
bloodstream
and releases toxins and can actually do
kidney failure it's something that we
haven't seen and I'm not kidding I think
like 80 years there's a clever cross
when a device that occurs here and there
yeah so that so there's the three
players that were hospitalized and
basically the coach that was training
them was trying to break them down
basically and you know doing certain
exercises that just really at the end of
the day he was just trying to break them
mentally and it was really for no reason
other than that there's no sports
performance you know aspect behind it
but a lot of a lot of coaches out there
when I talked a lot of high schools you
know strength coaches are a lot of
college drinkers when I go around
speaking to do in different places it's
just that I think we get so caught up in
kind of what we used to do right we miss
out on ultimately what's best for the
people we're working with and how can we
be on the you know front edges of that
of improving it I just I'm not
comfortable sitting here today saying I
accept where we are and as far as we
come in training that I'm willing to sit
them others just just use what we have
currently I want to push the limits I
think we're on the we barely even
scratch the surface on human on human
potential I think a lot of that has to
do with just regurgitating information
and and not people looking and seeking
out better ways to do something I think
that's my biggest thing is it's not so
much that I never speak in absolutes I
don't think we're ever we've ever
reached a finish line especially in this
field I think it's always you've got to
always kind of focus on this is what I'm
currently doing today I hope in two
years I have a better way to train
athletes than just X bar down if I
really truly do I hope the force number
is obsolete in two years because I hope
we've moved on to something that is
better and more and safer and and more
people can do it to help them improve
their performance and then at the end of
the day my goal would be is if you can
if you could even the playing field of
genetics and talent and you can actually
teach people how to be faster than just
going to come down or who works the
hardest is going to win and I think
that's what my goal is ultimately is not
to is to remove the veil of kind of
mystery of what makes somebody elite and
show okay here's here's here's what you
need to do if you could do these three
things do this over a long period of
time and it's just who's going to put
them the most work is going to reach
that goal and I think more and more you
know in other fields we're seeing that
but I think my goal with training is
just to kind of continue to push the
envelope and not accept kind of what is
and and kind of keep pushing forward
which which trainers or books have most
influenced or impressed you and the
reason I asked
Charlie Francis book on so Charlie I was
amazing and some of you may recognize
that name because he was the trader Ben
Johnson now at that level you don't have
to comment but I will say with a fair
degree of certainty not the only guy
doping in that race oh my god so I think
we've already got it back I haven't ever
gone back and seen that like eight of
the or seven of the eight people in that
race were doping it though oh yeah yeah
it's either me I think that's hard part
with Charlie that people miss out on the
genius purely based on kind of the story
with Ben and people thinking he's a bad
guy because he did but when it was just
the name of the game I mean I tell
people all the time if you're sitting in
a major league baseball locker room in
the late 80s early 90s and you're
looking around and you hit 20 home runs
a year before and the guy next you hit
12 and the following year he is 40 and
you're still hitting 20 at some point
you're going to go you know what I got
to give on what everybody else getting
on otherwise I'm not gonna be able to
play very much longer I think you know
it's kind of almost if there's a product
for the culture it's not so much an
isolated thing as much as people think
it is so yeah outside that no Charlie
France absolutely was a huge massive
influence on me another three-time
Olympian hurdler a guy with a Matt Tony
Campbell who became who's still a track
and field coach Joe was a huge influence
on me
dan path is one of I think brilliant
minds of of not just track and field the
training period he runs all just down to
Phoenix which is one of the largest kind
of attended track and field centers in
the world all sis alt us yeah alt us and
Dan path the PF AFF brilliant guy and
mind but you know I study everybody to
him honestly I've had I've got it from
you know Louis Simmons to Charles milk
and to all of them I mean for me it's
kind of like successfully excludes and I
think you've got to kind of study the
best that have done it prior to you and
she would see where we're at and do what
we can kind of add on to you know buddy
Morris is a strength coach the Arizona
Cardinals a really good friend of mine
the phenomenal coach
he's you know been in the game for a
very long time as in the sixties was
kind of a Louie Westside barbell guy but
as kind of adjusted to really evolved
and he's doing some phenomenal things
with them but yeah I mean there's a ton
of coaches III you know you know respect
incredibly I think I think it's been
awesome I think more than anything we we
as a field of performance coaches have
to kind of and what my goal is with Nike
to try to bring us together to kind of
get you know bringing all that
information together try to kind of come
with some best practices and try to help
move this field forward what is there
anything in particular from Louis
Simmons for you people who don't know
who release emesis you gotta look this
guy up and I'm not gonna say too much
more
he's very well-spoken very smart hey
check out his tattoos a really has to
say about anabolic steroids and then
look at the athletes who have come out
of his gym in the last 20 years and just
prepare to have your mind blown yeah if
you've ever seen people using chains or
bands chances are they they borrowed it
from Louie Simmons weren't they but is
there anything in particular that you
have borrowed or adapted from Louie that
comes to mind yeah absolutely when I
went to meet with him I you know one of
the big things he's talk to me about is
that it was all and it was just recently
but it all of his world record and and
you know world class squatters that he
has he box squats all of them to improve
their squat so his basic of a lifted
bucks was he uses that to help them
improve their deep squat in their
powerlifting competition so that was one
thing I started implementing more and
more with a lot of my jumpers a lot of
my football players is using more box
squats and then then then deep squat or
any type of variation of squad I use the
Box squat a ton not like a teaching tool
but just to help them improve their
other exercise with minimizing the risk
of injury and training question on box
squat just a technical nuance and are
you with your athletes when they box
squat how much of your weight how much
of their weight do you have them
transfer from their feet to their ass on
the box if at all or is it just making
contact and then reversing the movement
it just depends on the weight I'm using
and also kind of what what I'm going for
if I'm using if I'm using it like to do
tempo so if I'm doing like four seconds
down controlled tempo I may have them
just touch and go or I may have them it
just depends on where I'm at in the
phase of training or what I'm trying to
do to teach sometimes a lot of times
with newer athletes to box wedding I'll
actually have them fit completely down
on the bench on the on the on side on
the box kind of sit upright so their
spine angles is it's perpendicular to
the ground and then lean back forward
and stand back up just kind of get the
understanding of the sequencing of the
movement that I want from what I'm
saying that's what Louie does as well as
you actually have them sit completely
down in the box and so I kind of do a
combination of the two it's kind of
bends on the floor the the kind of phase
of the training I'm in but for the most
part of listeners I was dead probably
set all the way down in the box and then
you know sculture supine and go back
forward and back up when you're when
you're working with elite football
players or sprinters certainly I would
imagine they're already
they already tend to be very low body
fat there there are probably exceptions
depending on your eyes yeah they're
probably exceptions depending on the
position but we're talking about the
ground reactive force exactly but the
the amount of weight they can lift
relative to their body weight are there
cases where you focus simultaneously or
not on dropping as much body fat as
possible since that would ostensibly
contribute to their ability to run
faster right I mean you're just tweaking
it a different variable know how to
percent yeah a good example of that
actually a couple years ago I had two
quarterbacks in going coming into the
NFL Draft Marcus Mariota and Jameis
Winston and one came in at 270 needed to
be 225 the other one came in at 260 and
needed to be 230 so I actually had one
needing to gain 20 and the other one
needing to lose 30 and and have them at
the exact same time and so yeah this
ultimately can work for either what did
you do in both of those cases I know you
could probably talk for hours about it
but if you had to do your best to
summarize what worked best for those two
guys one trying to
cut fair amount of body fat and then the
other trying to gain mass what what were
the keys in those two cases no I mean I
yeah ultimately it comes down to I mean
as you know nutrition plays a massive
role in it and so blood testing I mean I
do a lot of blood sets work with with
the guys and so as you know with you
know high levels of insulin glucose is
really difficult to lose body fat so
understanding their diet from that
perspective of trying to lower that
those markers as much as possible
elimination those types of things that
have them lose body fat is crucial but
at the end of the day that's the really
cool part about a lot of this training
is that a lot of it is going to get you
to some sort of level of homeostasis
your body is going to try to get to its
natural state somewhat of a zero-based
all of this training so whether you need
to lose weight or you to put on muscle
your body's going to adapt and do what
it needs to do in order to increase its
strength especially when it's being
stressed at certain levels with the X
bar deadlift so with a guy like Marcus
we needed to gain 20 pounds I added a
lot more eccentric loading into his
training program so you do a lot more
tempo time their attention and focus on
the eccentric phase of some of the
exercises as well as the concentric so
an expert does it for example and have
him go up and down because we're looking
for more like cross-sectional fiber and
then and then with Jameis it was it was
a lot of concentric only letting me
limiting centric focus from his training
and then just upping the intensity and
also his cardio so just giving him some
some more cardio throughout the day and
for him a big part was just diet I mean
a lot of these kids coming out of
college a lot a lot of people don't
realize is that they have no idea how to
eat right or what is eating right
they've gotten away so much on talent up
to that point that all of a sudden comes
the point where oh wait I got to really
focus on at theat now you know so it's
like ya know McDonald's and KFC is not
not good for you which people if you
amazing how much they don't understand
that but I you know just helping him
with his dad was a big part so
ultimately the training doesn't need to
change as much it's like when you want
look at CrossFit for exams a great
example you'll see some people in the
gym over 60 days that will put on tons
of muscle mass and and you know and get
a bit stronger and bigger and you'll
look at the other side of the room and
some 105 pounds it's like how you know
how did them in the same workout same
programming over the past six days get
only different opposite result and
ultimately just because the body is
trying to find that that that that
Darrell Elm is they send souls whether
it's putting your fat cells or
increasingly muscle mass it's going to
do whatever you know the stresses is
asking it to do right what just a just a
couple more questions and I'll let you
back your night but the first question
that I always ask is what books have you
gifted the most to other people these
don't have to be sports related but they
could be are there are there any
particular books that you've gifted
ma'am
good question I've heard you ask this
before I didn't think you asked me those
should have been prepared for this but
I'm a huge huge avid reader I'm actually
believe I tell every person I trained
that I think a bit one of the biggest
reasons you are where you are difference
been where you are where you are where
you want to go is kind of knowledge I
began reading as much as you can and so
that's a tough question I think the
alchemist is a big one I've loved that
book for a very very long time the Bible
is a big one but I'll give you a kind of
an off off off the wall kind of one
which is called the slight edge in rid
of that book the slide edge the slight
edge of slight edge no and have it so
basically the premise of the book is and
I give it as many athing stuff also can
its basic the premises what you small
little tiny things you do the daily
habit you do every single day can lead
to exponential kind of implies
improvement down the road so it's
basically talks about forming habits
before they form you and and what types
of Abbott's you want to form so whether
it's things like you talk all the time
which is journaling nutrition you know
relationally like all those things that
you that that will help you lead a
greater fuller happier life kind of
making sure that you do those things and
where you do them religiously every
single day and over the course of time
like compounding interest it will add up
to something great at you know down the
road and it's all about just kind of
formed those habits and I bet something
I work with you know my athletes on all
the time because ultimately they've all
gotten to where they are but what
separates the great ones with all-time
athletes and people from from kind of
the you know the good is I think those
kind of just you know discipline daily
habits that they do every single day
that kind of you know make them who they
they are and that's what separates them
from everybody else they know who they
are they know that they can only do a
few things really really well and they
focus on those things and without
failing to him every single day you know
this I'm so embarrassed a camera over
the name but hey I love the title be it
reminds me of this anecdote or a story I
heard about one of the most famous
basketball coaches of the last century
certainly and I'm blanking on John
Wooden yes John Wooden and this may or
may not be true I think it is that he
would sit his players down at the
beginning of a season have them take off
their shoes and then have them lace
their shoes back on according to his
instructions and the point of the
exercise because people are like why the
hell are we doing this this is
ridiculous why do I need to change how
at least my shoes they said improperly
fitted shoes cause blisters blisters
cost points and points cost games and
the moral of the story being that it's
the little things done consistently that
make a huge difference now you have to
pay attention to the detail so I love
that display yeah yeah a lot of
percentage outside edge and it's a
redundant book it's just going over the
same things over and over again but it's
just it's kind of you know there's all
the self-help books out there that kind
of gives you like breaks or some certain
things this this one is awesome because
I kind of gives you the before all of
that happens you've got to be able to do
these things really well and it talks
about like four or five things that you
do daily that that just will add up at
some point they're good habit that will
that will pay off you know you know
exponentially and and I love it
what advice would you give your thirty
year old self and if you could just
place us where are you how old are you
right now I'm 34 okay forget about that
Commission 20 or what way yeah let's say
you're 20 or 25 year old self whichever
one needs the advice the most and if you
just try to place us where you are in
what you're doing
20 or 25 and I think I think the biggest
thing would be to I'll tell you a funny
story might so when I first started
doing this my my dad we always tell
people that I would let me nice too when
I first started as I started to figure
out what I want to do a training out I'm
at even so
out where I was like at a 24-hour
fitness I just wanted to get an idea of
like what I wanted to do and to this day
my dad still tells everybody I'm a
personal trainer I think pretty funny
well for multiple reasons but I think
it's like it's but I think more than
anything it's that whatever whatever
you're going to do be the absolute best
at it I think ultimately it always works
out in the end and and I would have
never thought a million years when I was
younger that like you know I thought I
was kind of with not being an athlete
and not being kind of you know I want to
be an orthopedic surgeon but not but not
having none of those things really work
out for me I would have never guessed I
would reach love looks at success what I
have today based on what I was doing but
I took so much pride in and and put so
much effort into like helping every
single person I came across to improve
that ultimately it kind of started to
add up and I think I just wanted to be
the best absolute best that I could be I
feel her the author CS Lewis yeah I was
heavily in a sauce about definitely
Screwtape Letters yeah yeah some great
but one of the big things he talks about
it's what's called the inner circle I
think was when I was talking to the
athletes um I work with um I was talking
about you know you're all they're always
striving to be within that inner circle
whether they see people like jay-z or
Beyonce or you know big-time athletes
that they like you know Tom Brady or
whoever they want to be in that circle
with those athletes because they see
them they're all hanging out running
around but ultimately those people know
in that inner circle they don't even
know they're in that inner circle the
reason they're in that inner circle is
because other people that were amazingly
great at what they did recognize their
greatness and what they did and that's
why the inner circles a lot of times
made up of photographers or actors or
musicians or athletes or all these
different types of people because
ultimately they're the best of what they
do and other greatness recognizes
greatness so instead of focusing on
getting into the inner circle focus on
being great at whatever you're doing and
I promise you there and look up and
you'll be in the inner circle I think
that's that's for me telling my younger
self that is that just just be great at
what you're doing and ultimately you'll
be recognized for that not not trying to
you know get into inner circle many of
the way I guess that make sense
makes perfect sense I well Ryan this has
been awesome this is a really glad we
connected and had a chance to chat I'm
sure we will have
a million follow-up questions from
listeners yeah and uh plenty of room for
round twos whether it's in Oregon or in
San Diego or somewhere else be fun too
to grab a bite to eat and do some
deadlifts but yeah we're where can
people find you if there's preferred
place on social media you'd like people
to say hello or anything else you'd like
to mention where can people find you and
more about your work yes or so I mean
I'm so working at Nike now so it's a
little bit different but I mean I'm on
Instagram
Ryan flirty one at Ryan flirty and the
number one and then by email just Ryan
at prolific athletes calm as I
personally am also send email questions
there if you guys would want and I'd be
happy to get back to as soon as I can I
think those are probably the two
probably best places to find me prolific
athletes calm and still epic but because
I'm at Nike now no longer really kind of
operating that website anymore so I
would just focus on sending the email or
Instagram got it alright well you may be
getting a lot of email sir yeah so
hopefully you have in the autoresponder
that helps you to ignore anything you
really don't want to answer but I once
again then thanks for for taking the
time this has given me a bunch of
homework and things to look into and to
people listening as always we will have
show notes links to resources including
the exercises that we discussed whether
it's glute Meade step downs internal
rotation of femur etc we will have these
available and we will figure out the
best links for those and put them in the
show notes and you can find those show
notes at 4-hour workweek dot-com forward
slash podcast or if that's too hard to
spell you can just go to tim dot blog
forward slash podcast and I'll have the
show notes for this episode in every
other episode Ryan thanks again man I
really appreciate it now my pleasure to
him thanks so much and to everybody
listening as always thank you for tuning
in and more episodes coming
hey guys this is Tim again just a few
more things before you take off number
one this is five bullet Friday do you
want to get a short email from me would
you enjoy getting a short email for me
every Friday is that provides a little
morsel of fun for the weekend
and five bullet Friday is a very short
email where I share the coolest things
I've found or that I've been pondering
over the week that could include
favorite new albums that have discovered
it could include gizmos and gadgets and
all sorts of weird that have
somehow dug up in the the world of the
esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I have read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to 4-hour workweek
dot-com that's 4-hour workweek com all
spelled out and just drop in your email
and you will get the very next one and
if you sign up I hope you enjoy it this
episode is brought to you by LegalZoom I
have used legals in myself for many of
my businesses and many of the icons on
this podcast have actually used Legal
Zoom for instance Matt Mullenweg of
WordPress Fame CEO of automatic which is
now worth more than a billion dollars
first incorporated his company on Legal
Zoom Legal Zoom is a reliable resource
that more than a million people have
already trusted to help with their
businesses whether that's setting up a
will doing a proper trademark search
forming an LLC setting up a non-profit
we're finding simple cease and desist
letter templates man do I use a lot of
those LegalZoom is not a law firm but
they do have a network of independent
attorneys available in most states they
can give you advice from the best way to
get started provide contract reviews and
otherwise help you run your business and
important there are no surprises Legal
Zoom provides complete transparency that
means upfront pricing customer reviews
and a satisfaction guarantee
check out legalzoom.com today to see how
they can make life better and easier for
you and your business if you're
pretending to be a lawyer on the
internet then you are asking for trouble
put together the safety nets get your
t's crossed and your eyes dotted and
promo codes tim t IM at legalzoom.com
to save 15% that's t IM for 15% off
check it out
legalzoom.com this episode is brought to
you by soothe dot-com the world's
largest on-demand massage service what
and let me tell you i have a high bar
for this stuff I have body work done at
least once a week because I broke my
body I have 30-plus fractures and
hundred plus MRIs I need body work so I
have a very very very high bar for that
soothed which I've tested I tested my
assistants tested my employees tested
delivers a hand-selected licensed and
experienced massage therapist to you in
the comfort of your own home Hotel our
office in as little as an hour I've
tested them in San Francisco I've test
them at Austin I've tested them all over
the place and I have to say I was really
really amazed at the quality of
therapists and I do not accept
mediocrity at all in this area the
process is super simple think of it as
Berber for massages right you choose the
kind of massage you want say Swedish or
sports massage deep tissue whatever then
if you want you can opt for a couples
massage I imagine that's an edge case as
the tech people say but whatever you set
the length your massage so let's say you
want 60 minutes 90 minutes two hours and
let's be real if you want a proper
massage go for ninety one hundred twenty
minutes for God's sake and you select
the gender of your therapist and then
click you're off to the races and they
bring the massage table sheets oil music
so you can unwind no matter where you
are and I have used this at Airbnb s
hotels etc students in 50 cities
including most major US cities as well
as the London Sydney Melbourne Toronto
and Vancouver so number one
download the app soothe soo th e in the
iOS App Store Google Play Store and then
use the
oh let me try that again use the code
Titans 20 TI ta n20 Titan 20 all caps to
get $20 off of your first massage that's
a lot that's a very good discount so you
should use it
so again download the app soothe soo th
e and try out the code tightness 20 all
caps for $20 not percent $20 off your
first massage and if you're anything
like me I have been paying and I've been
enjoying so give it a shot
try out soothe and your muscles nervous
system and sleep well thank you for it
what the kind of read with that it
was pretty good that's what I think okay
enjoy bye
[Applause]